et avec nous ce soir philippe froguel
généticien professeur à l'impérial
college de londres et à l'université
lille 2 pierre schwab
tellier membre du collectif intérieur
gens ces infirmiers à l'hôpital beaujon
bonsoir messieurs merci d'être en direct
avec nous ce soir sur rtl france votre
réaction pour commencer sur sept ce
certificat de vaccination est ce que
c'est une bonne ou une mauvaise idée
philippe froguel
est ce que c'est un impératif à médical
comme le souligne ursula von der leyen
je ne sais pas si c'est un impératif et
médical mais on sent bien un question on
veut partir prendre l'avion allait en
vacances ou même pour le travail d'aller
à l'étranger on va nous demander ça et
donc je pense que hélas ou heureusement
on va probablement vers quelque chose
comme ça qui va renforcer la nécessité
de se faire vacciner
je ne suis pas sûr que d'ailleurs être
vaccinés donne à 100% et la certitude
qu'on on introduira pas à l'étranger le
virus mais en tout cas je serais étonné
que on nous oblige pas à faire ça dans
les prochains mois c'est une manière
déguisée aussi de forcer la vaccination
pierre chauvin tellier on peut dire ça
comme ça après aujourd'hui le réel
problème c'est qu'on a pas de sens et
qu'on est soumis à yzeure sur la
conception des vaccins
donc là aujourd'hui on a une forte
devant de travail hospitalier de de
sutter vacciner c'est carrément des
bourses son camp et on va manquer de
vaccins
donc c'est un réel problème aujourd'hui
de l'acheminement et de logistique alors
on va revenir sur ces retards de
livraison arar annoncé par faïza mais
avant cela le comité d'urgence de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
s'est opposé pour le moment à l'idée
d'un certificat de vaccination il met en
avant trop d'inconnues en termes
d'efficacité des vaccins pour réduire la
transmission du virus vous en parlais à
l'instant philippe froguel
c'est tellement rassurant ce genre de
propos non c'est pas rassurant mais
c'est là la situation réelle
il ya tout un débat sur première dose
deuxième dose
il ya un débat aussi sur l'efficacité
des autres vaccins comme astrazeneca
l'camp toujours pas été acceptée
les chinois qui sont pas apparemment peu
efficace tout ça est très très compliqué
je comprends leur ordination médiane
mondiale de la santé avant de rendre
obligatoire quelque chose peut-être se
mettre d'accord de pommes parle de quel
vaccin
combien de doses et comment si on oblige
les gens à faire ça faut aussi que ça
soit ouvert aujourd'hui en france la
réalité c'est qu'on est en pénurie et
qu'on n'arrivera pas à l'objectif de 15
millions de personnes vaccinées
rapidement et donc obligé des gens varin
une sorte de passeport d'immunité alors
que en réalité hirayama pas bon tout le
monde c'est quand même problématique et
la réalité en france aussi c'est donc on
est effectivement dépendante de files
heures le laboratoire américain qui a
donc annoncé plusieurs semaines de
retard de livraison de son vaccin à
compter de la fin du mois on l'a entendu
pour l'union européenne
elle n'en fera pas les doses attendu au
premier trimestre dans l'europe elles
seront livrées comme prévu selon la
présidente de la commission européenne
et pourtant
l'exécutif français a annoncé tout à
l'heure qu'il devra ajuster le rythme
des vaccinations qu'on a du mal un peu à
comprendre ce qui se passe ce retard ou
par retard comment est-ce que vous
interprétez cette réaction de l'exécutif
pierre schwach tellier non on voyait
venir depuis quelque temps comme on dit
on depuis quelques semaines on va
changer on a adapté les normes si vous
voulez on a vu que ça sentait la pénurie
on est passé de 5 à 6 12
on est passé de 21 jours à six semaines
pour le deuxième appel enfin on voit
bien qu'on est en train de s'adapter
comme on a pu connaître lors de la
première vague au niveau des normes sur
les masques et des gants
fabien on est on s'adapte à chaque fois
sur la pénurie et le manque hélas
aujourd'hui la pénurie allait bien
à l'abord à coire taylor qui ne à cause
d'un brevet déposé en réalité on dépend
totalement de pfizer sur un vaccin qui
aujourd'hui protège à 95% apparemment
selon les statistiques ons qui devrait
produire en masse et on est complètement
dépendant du dépendant de ça on avait de
pénurie philippe froguel
le laboratoire américain pfizer se
défend finalement c'est retardé à les
prochaines livraisons pour les
multiplier ou en tout cas dépasser
l'objectif qui était initialement fixée
alors deux choses
moi je ne suis pas convaincu par les
explications de file
et je pense qu'il faut quand même posé
la question ce qui se passe vraiment
parce que dire qu'ils ont besoin faire
des nouvelles études pour d'autres
autorisations moi ça m'inquiète un petit
peu de quoi il parle
est ce que c'est le procédé de
fabrication est ce que c'est le vaccin
lui même moi je trouve ça un petit peu
inquiétant je suis un peu étonné que la
commission européenne ne nous est pas
donné plus de renseignements là dessus
le pourfendeur il s'agit de modifier le
processus de production pour augmenter
la cadence et ce qui met en avant en
tout cas pour être plus rapide pour
dépasser l'objectif et atteindre les
deux milliards de doses en 2021 ce qui
serait plus qu'initialement annoncé là
la chose qu'il faudrait faire en réalité
c'est d'ouvrir deux nouvelles usines
il ya des débats des discussions sur
sanofi par exemple qui pourrait produire
en france les vaccins riser ou en
allemagne et aussi des discussions
là-dessus on arrive à cette situation
que on va arrêter en fait là lusine
unique en europe belle belge pour
augmenter sa production c'est un jeu
c'est parce que ce qu'on peut en penser
mais c'est c'est quand même un peu
étonnant cette façon de faire au
produire plus on va produire moins
maintenant c'est sûr un contexte de
pénurie réelle puisque le gouvernement
français avait tablé l'été dernier sur
15 millions de vaccinés on s'aperçoit
maintenant qu'il en faudrait bien 25
millions et il est impossible que le
gouvernement français fasse ce qu'il
avait prévu de faire au premier
trimestre et des gens comme moi avaient
prédit que d'une part c'était patients
qu'astrazeneca arrive et le sait puisque
boris johnson a fait tout ce qu'il a pu
pour que ça reste en angleterre plus
longtemps et que avec une usine unique
il pouvait arriver des problèmes
industriels c'est arrivé alors à partir
de lundi va commencer la vaccination
pour les plus de 75 ans avec une
conséquence directe pour les hôpitaux
d'ile-de-france 1 qui avait organisé
dans l'urgence début janvier la
vaccination des professionnels de santé
de plus de 50 ans puisqu'ils vont devoir
rediriger leurs stocks de vaccins vers
les centres de vaccination c'est une
mise en concurrence
comment est ce que vous avez accueilli
cette annonce
de l' agence régionale de santé pierre
chatelier j'ai pas du tout étonnée je
veux dire ça fait quelques semaines que
dans les médias on tape un peu sur les
soignants et les paramédicaux parce
qu'ils refusent de soigner je comprends
maintenant la logique politique derrière
de dire en gros comme on veut pas se
soigner quand on voit pas pardon se
faire vacciner on va récupérer les
vaccins les hôpitaux
j'ai discuté avec beaucoup de médecins
concernant ce sujet sa critique beaucoup
et ça bloque
en l'occurrence de croix que martin a
confirmé sociaux nigaud développer ou de
l'acheter parce que véritablement ça
bloque la réalité il ya il ya une
demande
ils vont être les répercussions alors
concrètement sur le personnel soignant
selon vous ah bah oui c'est très
clairement là il ya une colère sont en
train de monter qui était présente
depuis quelques temps on était un petit
peu fatigué épuisé depuis ces dernières
semaines mais là on commence un petit
peu à s'énerver parce qu'on se moque de
nous le tracleer mans on nous envoie sur
la première vague sans protection
maintenant on le dit fréquemment qu'on
aura pas de vaccins on veut pas se faire
vacciner en fins et ont commencé à
s'énerver
alors cette ouverture de la vaccination
lundi au plus de 75 ans elle a commencé
avec un couac heures impossibles vient
de réserver sa place le site a buggé ça
fait partie du jeu ou alors c'est quand
même difficilement admissible selon vous
philippe froguel
non c'est pas admissible déjà on a
arrêté pour les ehpad
il ya que si j'ai bien compris 23% des
les ehpad que l'on commence à être
vaccinés ce qui est pas lourd donc on
est très très très loin d'avoir vacciné
750 mille résidents des ehpad et quant
aux personnes âgées qui vont bien ce
qu'elles sont pas dans les ehpad qui
sont beaucoup plus nombreux c'est quand
même le très très très grand cas
aujourd'hui et selon les endroits
particulièrement en région parisienne
c'est un un cas où un insensé avec des
sites qui fonctionnent pas ou des
rendez-vous qui sont un mois et demi
c'est c'est quelque chose qui est
indescriptible qui a enfreint entraîné
surtout avec cette arrivée aujourd'hui
de la troisième vague et de là
la souche anglaise entraîner des très
grandes prestations
cette vaccination nécessite deux
injections en est aujourd'hui à la
première elle se déroule au compte
gouttes on le voit bien est-ce qu'on n'y
verra pas plus clair sur la réussite de
cette campagne de vaccination une fois
que les deux injections auront bien été
réalisés et justement au sujet de ces
deux injections à pierre chatelier et ce
qu'on voudrait on parle avouent
soignants et on est très focalisée
aujourd'hui sur la première injection
quid de la deuxième parce qu'il ya un
délai à respecter quand même balle en
question on est passé de 21 une semaine
de l'un des agents pendant six semaines
ce qui est dans les recherches de la
boîte à 16h10 comme acceptable mais le
laboratoire taylor lui même a dit qu'il
ne garantissait absolument rien donc en
fait on est dans un club et on pose la
question il répond tout simplement on ne
sait pas parce qu'on a l'impression
aussi un que chaque pays il va donc de
sa propre initiative les laboratoires
effectivement alerte sur l'efficacité du
vaccin qui dépendent d'un certain délai
entre les injections en france c'est
quoi officiellement la règle philippe
froguel
voilà la règle au départ c'était à trois
semaines c'est ce qui a été prévu moi
j'ai été vacciné semaine dernière j'ai
eu tout de suite un rendez vous trois
semaines plus tard
mais on me dit que pour les gens qui
sont fait vacciner
quelques jours après moi ça sera à six
semaines donc en fait c'est la pénurie
qui a dicté sa sais c'est pas du tout à
quelque chose de deux médical et les
conséquences sur l'efficacité ça va ça
risque d'avoir des conséquences sur
l'efficacité du vaccin au final on peut
pas répondre aujourd'hui puisque ça a
été mise au point et ça a été accepté
avec les certifications qui sont une
deuxième injection au bout du bout de
trois semaines maximum
effectivement une quarantaine de jours
parce que ça a été fait comme ça
personne n'est capable de nous dire
aujourd'hui si c'est si ça va diminuer
l'efficacité vaccinale mais c'est pas
pour des raisons médicales que sa
défaite et pour des raisons simples en
de logistique parce qu'on n'a pas assez
de doses vaccinales
vous diriez aujourd'hui pierre chatelier
qu'on est dans une gestion de la
vaccination au plus tôt dans une gestion
de l'insuffisance de dos quel est votre
ressenti
j'ai commencé mais toujours dans la
gestion de la peña et on connaît ça
c'est on est habitué maintenant depuis
un an on ne fait que ça de la gestion de
pénurie on n'a pas les vaccins mais
certains ch ça je n'aime pas les bonnes
aiguilles ou les bonbonnes sera donc ça
tout ça n'inspire clairement pas
confiance façon pour faire vacciner mais
c'est vraiment de la gestion de pénurie
mais voilà on s'adapte on est dans la
gestion de pénurie pour vous aussi
philippe froguel
oui et aussi d'un prête d impréparation
parce que il est absolument clair que
début octobre
nous n'avions aucun plan de vaccination
le plan de vaccination il a été
improvisée à la hâte
quand les premières doses allait arriver
c'est à dire à la l'autorisation des
vaccins riser du vaccin pfizer c'était
le seul à l'époque et on n'avait pas ce
plan est là le paradoxe aujourd'hui
cette cure n'a dans les free et dans les
frigos et congélateurs et centaines de
milliers de 12 qui ne sont pas utilisés
et la pénurie globale ou là mais au
niveau local il ya des congélateurs qui
sont plaint qu'ils ont pas utilisé
c'est que c'est complètement délirant la
situation aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup à tous les deux un
philippe froguel généticien ans
professeur à l'impérial college de
londres et à l'université lille 2 pierre
schwab tellier infirmier à l'hôpital
beaujon dans les hauts-de-seine et
membre du collectif inter urgence merci
messieurs et à bientôt